hello there reject nation we are here to
watch what episode is this john it's
episode eight of season two of gravity
falls
ladies and gentlemen leave a like that'd
be very much appreciated also subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction for
gravity falls is up here on the channel
full length watch along three sync up
with the time code are available over
for our super sexy rejects at our
patreon page over there we cover several
shows with the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch alongs included lastly the team of
prepper thank you for helping us edit
down these highlights for being a
beautiful extension of this channel
alright guys let's get to it
[Music]
oh my god the future guy from rick and
morty when the episode looks like rick
and morty
he's either the bravest time convict
i've ever seen or the dumbest
or both my time knee oh time dang it
dumbest freeze don't
crazy son of a [ __ ] the two kids that
ruined my life dipper and mabel pines
21st century
may time baby have mercy on their souls
this is going to go well i wonder what
the behind the scenes is with who does
the voice of justin rollins yeah justin
roiland royland uh i wonder what the
behind the scenes is of
[Music]
candy candy candy
no it's trap my yumberjacks hey dudes
you want to know a trick beverty bope
womp a genius taught me that once
weather stations are calling for a candy
blizzard
zeus you are the greatest human ever to
live
that was a mistake
oh i'd do anything for the pines family
i need to scratch myself in two places
at once coming mr pines do what you do
zeus better make sure he gets his wallet
back wait i've never seen seuss's wallet
before don't you want to learn some
sue's secrets steal his identity
earth day july 13th i wonder why he
didn't tell anyone probably because he
wants someone to throw him a surprise
party surprise
too little too late chew
some friend you are
and uh twins are born birthday experts
we've shared every birthday together so
we know how to make them perfect
hey places everyone nice i'm just a
giant hummingbird so i'm expecting to
see a giant hummingbird three two one
happy birthday you king on earth cake
flavored pizza pizza flavored cake
everyone posed for the birthday smiles
memory album
[Music]
what's wrong it's nothing i uh
i gotta go fix a pipe or something buddy
but sus hates his birthday what there's
gotta be something we can do i even
petitioned the government to have this
day removed from calendars now i'm not
allowed on airplanes
[Music]
what's wrong you got to get a time
machine and fix this there's got to be a
way to cheer them up we just need to try
harder all right guys blindfold me once
shame on you blindfold me twice wait a
minute
hot dog smell sticky floors
you know what it is
i love laser tag how'd you guys know
welcome to the year 8000 society
collapsed fog machines everywhere
i don't know guys i'm not sure i'm up
for this today as soon as you start
playing with us you're gonna have a
great time well i guess i could give it
a shot
[Applause]
oh better find all these cowboys
no you're leaving his side look how real
these laser guys are
kick deflected thank you for buying
digicon the smart cod piece wait what
digicod
i need one there's only one way out of
here through me
and that's what it would have been like
if i had just gotten it right the very
first chance but it still is effective
time traveler guy what did you say your
name was again blindo blondin
blarblar there it is it's blindin
initiate flashback i was cast out of the
time anomaly removal crew my whole
life's purpose i spent every day since
then planning my vengeance
and now finally it has come
congratulations
it's our friend's birthday today and we
promised we wouldn't leave his side do
you know where you are welcome
to globnar
[Applause]
oh
yeah
oh cool
the winner gets a precious time wish
and then decides the loser's fate
no please
[Music]
wowie
dipper we need a way out of here but how
i have an idea hang in there seuss we're
coming for you
dipper
mabel requesting backups oh
no
calcium laser robbie
[ __ ]
laser his face
luffy
it's me
you're great great great great great
great great grandmother
from the pastimes
damn cam
huh stop them
damn cam how could you i ain't no one
scam damn sucker you just got time
tripped
[Music]
to susan's uh
okay i think
this will go well
[Music]
oh no look
when it was still a mattress start
far in the past time travel why you
gotta be so complicated
don't don't think about it destination
by ten years i don't see them you better
find those kids you'll get your justice
blenden i'm gonna keep stammering until
you find them i i i i i i
ten years we can be back before soos
even realizes we were gone oh no
the tiny thing it's busted i think i
know where to get some
[Music]
let's try to lay low oh
he doesn't have his chin and head
tattoos yet broadway here i come
this stream goes nowhere toby
oh
marbles
keep at it toby my friend thinks you're
cute oh my gosh
no whoa
you're super young so this is weird now
you know how she feels creep yeah i uh
huh
wow
dang
grooming wendy
[Music]
bingo all right let's see ah come on
candy fall
the origins
jackpot
thanks dog you must be some kind of
genius
all right i think i've got this thing
working
she's the one who taught him you don't
want to be late for your big day sorry
abuelita we could finally find out why
seuss hates his birthday all right but
let's be quick who's a handsome birthday
boy it's you i see why he hates it eh
this looks great oh sorry dude but could
you move seats that's a seat of honor
it's for my dad actually
oh that must be him
ah poor zeus
all right seuss today's the big day be
cool be cool
postcard for sorry champ couldn't make
it hey don't sweat it cuz you'll see him
next year
yeah
next year
ah
that's why soos hates his birthday it's
the day he realized his dad wasn't
coming back how much partying can fix
that
a lot
it's the party young robbie young
[Music]
zeus i made you cookie shaped like
dinosaurs i want to see dad again and he
wants to see you he's just busy you will
feel better one day
[Music]
she drugged him
sooner i defeat those kids in globnar
the sooner i can win my time wish tell
you what i do if i had a time wish
retire early spend more time with the
kids
don't you know a time wish can literally
do anything any impossible problem
solved just like that i mean imagine the
possibility
the time wish we defeat blending in that
space battle then we can wish that sis's
dad came to his 12th birthday and
susan's birthdays would be fixed forever
all of them oh you guys are nice
here we are blendin we surrender it's
them freeze careful they're from the
past they might have powder muskets or
slap braces
or pogs let the clomnar begin prepare
more
[Music]
initializing
a screwdriver is gonna change everything
in the past
holy moly welcome global tributes you
each have a chance to settle your time
feud through gladiatorial combat you
will have until time baby finishes
drinking the cosmic sand in this
hourglass no come on
yes
you wish you were never born or rather
you wish you were born because i'm gonna
wish you were never born there's two of
us and we have hair i have training
oh
[Applause]
come on guys
[Music]
oh
[Music]
how long does it take to eat that drink
that bottle you have escaped the cyclops
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do you know the one who touches the
victory orb first will win
laser tag seriously oh i know it doesn't
seem that challenging now but just wait
until they turn on that fog machine uh
oh man mabel grab the arm
it is
uh
finished
you have made victory in globe now
before i give you your time wish what
fate do you decide for the loser
oh
oh
we'd like to set blendin free and
restore his position at the time anomaly
correction unit and give him pretty hair
you do that for me i got my job back i
can kill you in eight different ways
thank you the wish isn't for us who is
worthy to receive such power
huh that's unconventional
[Laughter]
guys we're so sorry we left you hanging
dude the point is i think we know how to
fix your birthday oh really and that's
not all
behold your time wish we think the only
thing that can make you happy is meeting
your dad but the choice is yours
[Music]
wait what fixed you up you had a
gladiator fight just to make me happy i
know who my family is now and it's you
dudes thanks for giving me the best
birthday ever oh
oh that's not all dudes i also wished
for this slice of infinite pizza oh
i'm all amazing that's a good time wish
there's still time
you dudes want to play yeah
come on blendin
you are single-handedly the worst
handyman i've ever seen you're hired one
size fits all step right up to the
mystery shack folks step right up
oh his dad origins that's how he found
his father figure oh
everything's explained now a circle
circle of time
that was sweet
that was really sweet and inventive and
creative
i would have liked to have maybe spent a
little bit more time with you know the
actual
match
of of the all the craziness and stuff
like i was down for a cool laser tag
battle
like i love laser tag and while look
watching this episode made me go [ __ ] i
had to go back laser tag and there's one
like five minutes away from here and i
haven't been in years
it's like some virus kind of ruined that
for me but i i love i love laser tagging
so i wanted to see like the futuristic
spin on it you know like getting some
tributes and things i felt like running
man and tron you know a lot of sci-fi
riffs i thought was great bringing back
the baby i remember that baby being
teased in um for the first episode of
blood and blandin's episode and uh
because i was right at the very end if
i'm not mistaken but you know to have
something that was just more
about appreciating those like
stories about time traveling but really
bad it's about now you know not living
in the past or being concerned about the
future
but being appreciative for what you have
in the present
and you know because i was thinking to
myself too that if he did make his wish
to get his dad back
like what kind of lesson is that really
because there's a lot of people who do
struggle with parental issues or
abandonment and whatnot and uh you know
a lot of the times it is about learning
how to cope with today and
to see what good things have come and to
you know so i feel like the message is
even stronger this way
versus
you know him getting a wish to see his
deadbeat father basically yeah yeah
totally and and then you also have that
nice compliment with the fact that they
you know choose to be merciful on
blendin like i think they they do nicely
to to uh subvert
yeah where you think it's heading and
and do things that are sweeter and more
quality overall
and uh yeah i pretty much totally agree
it's like the one thing i could have
used maybe is a little bit of tension to
be like oh man is blending gonna
actually win this
um but as it stood i mean i like their
journey through time and the little you
know drop in the screwdriver sending
soos on his way to the mystery shack
through that and uh yeah like little
wendy just like the the the fun and
games they made throughout time on the
way i thought were really fun and too
you know for who this show is geared at
i think yeah that's the perfect way to
wrap it up because a lot of kids
probably do have to grapple with that
weird you know
dynamic of where's my dad why isn't he
here you know like he seems to he writes
me these notes it sounds like he might
care but ultimately realizing that yeah
you know the people around you who are
actually there and who are actually
trying to help are the ones that you
should invest that emotional time into
instead of yeah pining for somebody who
isn't pining for you
yeah exactly and then also because time
travel
you know if you don't overthink rules
about it but i like when they do weird
things like that of like closing time
loops and oh this is how this person was
in the past like having like little
wendy be like oh my god you're actually
really cute uh to dipper
or to having the
the whole thing with the screwdriver
that leads into showing how
zeus became part of the mystery shack
and um oh there was another good one oh
yeah the whole thing was like the
vending machine of a genius showed him
and a little robbie like i think the i
think a little young rabbit yeah
i think a lot of those easter eggs are
actually um a lot of fun so yeah i mean
i'm a sucker for a time travel [ __ ] like
i just think that's super fascinating
and entertaining and
you know it's it
preys on i think time travel prays on a
on a very something that's kind of
primal in a weird way even though it's
like it's not real um or is it but you
know it's not real or it's not
accessible for that matter
or is it and it's something i think a
lot of us kind of wish for you know
because it could just play on the whole
thing of wanting to see what the future
is like what time might be like when
we're not around or fixing things from
the past you know uncovering that so i
think that's why time travel is such a
timely subject
and i love i like i liked what they did
here overall it was it was a lot of fun
and i thought it might be more centric
on blend and blend in but for what we
got to make something that just
humanizes zeus more and makes steven
abuelita more
of a character this time around and is
something that's actually pretty human
for someone to deal with
i liked it i appreciate it thought it
was really heartwarming and
good good time travel story that's right
man that's right
the barriers of time are precious thing
i guess yeah it's it is like as fanciful
and fun and well worn of a sci-fi trope
as it is time travel is something primal
to me because i think everybody at some
point feels
how thin the veil of time is when you
make a mistake or when you realize that
you know here at the same time
you know whoever i want to see or
whatever they're coexisting with me in
this moment and if only we could bridge
that gap like there's so many ways to
bargain with time and i feel like that's
part of why it's so enduring as a topic
of fiction
yeah
plus two just futuristic game world you
know always like a good dystopia
good glimpse into some kind of far-off
citadel someone's going to have a more
serious discussion about this episode of
gravity falls in us and that's why you
guys come here
for the serious talks the dramatic
inclinations behind this young adult
show
this queen aid show
alright guys well thank you so much for
being here thank you for joining us on
this gravity falls journey
and hey we'll catch you all soon
[Music]